[Music]
some politicians are now saying that
americans shouldn't be allowed to vote
unless they can pass the same
naturalization test that immigrants need
to pass in order to become citizens okay
now people are debating this one way or
the other i gotta go on a limb i
actually think it's a great idea i
really do and to prove it i'm gonna do
something that i don't think many people
on television do i'm gonna once again
take the u.s citizenship test
citizenship
laugh at my small stroke
how well is this going to go if i can't
say citizenship you did just fine i'm
going to take the u.s citizenship test
right now on the air with some help from
andy don't you think that's
courageous well exists
now
these are pretty tough questions i've
looked at them i don't care if they're
tough i think i can do it and i'm going
to do it yes now that you've mastered
the language
all right
here we go all right are you ready in
the booth all right all right
question number one gotcha here we go
what are the two major political parties
in the united states democrats and
republicans who was the first president
of the united states george washington
what is the american dream to work in
sweatpants
who made the first american flag betsy
ross
and who makes them now the people's
factory in the province of guangzhou
china right
how many stars are there on the american
flag 69 dude up high
what are the opening lyrics to the doors
la woman well i just got into town about
an hour ago now give me what everybody
thinks they are well the diego little
doggie about an hour ago
name three events from from american
history using sexual innuendo uh the
boston tea bag party
the [ __ ] of 1812
and the attack on pearl necklace harbor
nice
snoopy or garfield snoopy yeah
craigslist or ebay what am i getting a
couch with six blood spots on it
craigslist yeah
what is the smallest minority in the u.s
uh black people who like wayne brady
right
what is the best topless bb kate's and
fast times at richmond high
okay uh knock knock who's there the
greatest country on the face of the
earth oh you mean the united states of
america yes up high dude
uh what is the 17th amendment to you to
the u.s constitution uh 17th amendment
established direct election of united
states senators by popular vote also
altered the procedures for filling
vacancies in the senate allowing for
state legislatures to permit the
governors to make temporary appointments
until a special election be held but
critics of the 17th amendment claim it
has led to an over-extension of federal
powers and the rise of special interest
groups to fill the power vacuum
previously occupied by state
legislatures resulting in what many call
to reform or even repeal the 17th
amendment
all right and finally
what would arnold schwarzenegger say if
he killed someone with a knife who was
about to get married i now pronounce you
man and knife
[Applause]